die überraschende kandidatur ursula von
der leyen für das amt der
kommissionspräsident in brüssel schlägt
natürlich auch in berlin sofort hohe
wellen
zum einen in der koalition aus spd und
union die spd ist alles andere als
amüsiert
ihr kandidat für den kommissionsplänen
viel zu präsident der kommission bleiben
das natürlich ein hoher posten aber
nicht das was er angestrebt hat
ansonsten ist so furchtbar viel für die
spd nicht im topf sie hat gleich
proteste angemeldet doch noch ein
zweites problemfeld tut sich auf und das
ist die union selber die sich im letzten
jahr wahnsinnig verkracht hatte über die
flüchtlingspolitik die jetzt ist die csu
natürlich sauer dass ihr kandidat
manfred weber auch zunächst einmal
nichts wird und günstigstenfalls in
zweieinhalb jahren vizepräsident des
europäischen parlamentes dass es weit
weniger als er und seine partei sich
erhofft hatten aber auch die kandidatin
selbst wird vorsichtig sein beim jubeln
denn sie kann nicht vergessen haben dass
sie ja schon einmal fast etwas ganz
großes geworden wäre nämlich
bundespräsidentin nach dem rücktritt von
horst köhler und damals hatte sie sich
eingebildet angela merkel wolle dass sie
das amt übernehme bekanntlich hat merkel
das nicht gewollt bekanntlich ist von
der leyen ist nicht geworden